on marche sur la tête pour le moment le
dossier du jour on va revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé à Bordeaux au moins 12
personnes ont été intoxiquées au
botulisme et une personne est morte
après avoir consommé des sardines en
conserve dans un restaurant cette
personne sont toujours en réanimation
toutes les mêmes personnes ont mangé au
même endroit le titre
alors que s'est-il vraiment passé c'est
quoi ce fameux botulisme dans quel état
sont les personnes j'ai mis le ramani le
docteur chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital franco-britannique va être
avec nous dans un instant petit récap de
cette histoire Gilles vous allez nous la
raconter aussi elle est incroyable
[Musique]
une affaire sanitaire importante qui
secoue la région bordelaise c'est donc
une très grave intoxication qui a
déclenché l'alerte des autorités
plusieurs personnes ont récemment été
touchées par une maladie neurologique
très
rare par an
leur nerfs sont bloqués par la toxine
botulinique et cette toxine peut rester
en place plusieurs semaines pour leur
une personne est décédée et plusieurs
ont été hospitalisés dont certains qui
ont dû être placés sous assistance
respiratoires point commun de toutes les
victimes avoir mangé des sardines mal
conservées dans un bar un mode
opératoire très artisanal et dès ce jour
nous lui avons demandé de ne plus
fabriquer de conserves maison alors
quelles sont les causés les conséquences
de cette maladie qui attaquent le
système nerveux cas de botulisme à
Bordeaux êtes-vous inquiet
alors Gilles avant d'en parler avec
Docteur Jamil ramani on est très heureux
de vous avoir chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital
franco-britannique je le suis plus vous
n'êtes toujours pour moi je vous
réhabilite alors vous êtes plus ça y est
vous avez arrêté vous êtes tranquille je
travaillais ailleurs
dans une clinique d'accord on n'a pas le
droit de le dire non si vous cherchez
deux infirmières
juste on va revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé docteur avec Gilles Verdez mais
entre le 4 et le 17 septembre dans un
bar de Bordeaux un bar à vin toi tu t'es
pris pour Michel Marion
ce qui s'est passé voilà on va pas
rigoler là-dessus mais tu nous dis si
c'est passé arrête de te la raconter
des gens en consommer des sardines en
conserve cette maison c'est un bar qui
est fréquenté beaucoup par des touristes
anglo-saxons donc c'est des gens qui
pour certains sont repartis et 25
personnes auraient consommé ces sardines
qui ont été mal conservés et qui donc
alors
ils ont fait eux-mêmes
comment on fait des sardines je sais pas
mais il est conserve les conserves sont
faites maison c'est-à-dire que tout le
procédés de stérilisation justement a
été mal fait c'est ça le gros risque et
donc à l'intérieur il y a une bactérie
qui déclenche le botulisme qui peut être
mortel et qui d'ailleurs l'est et donc
il y a 25 personnes qui selon les
enquêteurs ont consommé ces sardines
docteur c'est quoi leur botulisme alors
le boutulise c'est une maladie qui est
due à une bactérie qui s'appelle la
une toxine qui est toxique pour les
nerfs et donc ça entraîne des paralysies
alors ça commence pas une paralysie de
l'oeil ça donne ce qu'on appelle une
DIPLINE vision double ça donne des ça
peut donner des maux de tête et des
troubles digestifs et puis la paralysie
descend et dans les cas les plus graves
vous avez une paralysie respiratoire qui
entraîne la mort qui peut entraîner la
mort c'est mortel dans 10 à 20% des cas
alors là on a vu que voilà c'était
extrêmement grave puisque le bilan est
très lourd très lourd il y a un mort 7
personnes donc ils sont en réanimation
et on recherche encore il y a un cas en
Espagne et il y a quelqu'un qui est
reparti en Allemagne qui aurait été
touché aussi donc on recherche
éventuellement d'autres victimes et les
enquêteurs disent à tous les gens qui
ont fréquenté le bar Cyril la semaine
dernière de se présenter à eux parce que
ça peut se déclencher tardivement ça
peut se déclencher dans les heures qui
suivent l'ingestion mais ça peut se
déclencher 3 à 4 jours voire cinq jours
plus tard
alors le problème de cette maladie c'est
qu'elle est extrêmement grave et qu'il
faut agir tout de suite dans les 24
heures on a des antitoxines on sait les
fabriquer et qui marche mais ça n'agit
que dans les 24 premières heures donc il
faut se rendre compte très vite très
vite si on a tout à fait si on a des
symptômes si on voit double si on a du
mal à déglutir si on a la bouche sèche
et bien il faut s'inquiéter et surtout
si on a consommé des sardines dans ce
dans ce bar alors le problème c'est que
c'est sardines ont été mal stérilisés
quand les conserves sont mal stérilisés
et bien ça permet la prolifération de la
de la bactérie qui sécrète la toxine
botulique que tout le monde connaît bien
la toxine botulique c'est le Botox ah
d'accord c'est ça d'accord oui ce qui
est très étonnant aussi je trouve c'est
que le propriétaire du bar a ouvert les
boîtes il a vu que ça sentait mauvais
mais c'est ça il en a acheté
quelques-unes et là on a servi d'autres
là quand même je trouve qu'il a fait
preuve d'une certaine bien sûr si vous
ouvrez une boîte de conserve qui a de
l'air qui sort qui a un gaz qui sort si
ça sent mauvais et si la boîte est
gondolée et bien il faut surtout pas
consommer surtout pas et docteur c'est
quoi le remède parce que donc je crois
pas qu'il y a des médicaments dans la
fin le
romanique pas dans les pharmacies c'est
juste
il faut se rendre immédiatement à
l'hôpital quand on a ces signes et
surtout c'est un traitement après passer
les 24 heures c'est un traitement qu'on
dit symptomatique c'est-à-dire que si
vous avez une insuffisance expiratoire
et bien on vous met sous machine alors
le problème c'est que les séquelles
peuvent être très lourdes parce que la
toxine bottine unique entraîne une
destruction enfin une une destruction
une dégénérescence des nerfs et pour que
les nerfs se mettent à repousser ça peut
prendre des mois et ça peut arriver avec
n'importe quel aliment c'est à dire que
les gens qui nous regardent par exemple
quand ils vont au restaurant qui mangent
quelle est la probabilité que ça puisse
arriver mon chiffre ça à 0,8 pour
millions d'habitants en France
c'est-à-dire que il y a en bonhomme
allant 15 à 20 cas par an en France
c'est donc très rare
5 à 25 cas par an c'est ça voilà c'est
ça
le restaurateur il risque quoi alors moi
ce qui m'a d'abord japonais c'est que le
restaurant est fermé quelques jours mais
là il va désinfecter et il aura le droit
de rouvrir j'avoue que j'ai été très
étonné je sais pas si vous trouvez ça
normal certes c'était dans des sardines
mais nous on n'a pas envie de mettre des
bons chômage non mais c'est quand même
très étonnant qu'il rouvre aussi vite
tant qu'à pas te plainte de déposer
plein de déposer qui est une entorse et
à ce moment-là effectivement il peut y
avoir une fermeture administrative je
pense que lui voilà lui il est là
aujourd'hui il doit dans un défi
il y a 7 personnes en réanimation qui
sont entre la vie et la mort au moment
où nous parlons comment ces personnes
sont traitées est-ce qu'elles ont des
chances de s'en sortir oui oui la
mortalité c'est entre 10 et 20% d'accord
le traitement à base d'antitoxines c'est
dans les 24 heures c'est là que ça
marche c'est avant que les signes
respiratoires n'apparaissent mais après
passer ce temps si on a dessiné une
respiratoire et bien c'est l'assistance
respiratoire avec machine et on peut
garder des séquelles longtemps
malheureusement très bien merci Docteur
de nous avoir éclairé là-dessus ce soir
parce que c'était vraiment quand même
par défaut qui a énormément tourné
aujourd'hui on vous donnera des
nouvelles bien sûr des autres personnes
hospitalisées merci beaucoup merci à
vous dire quand vous voulez c'est
toujours un bonheur on va parler des
smartphones c'est dangereux les
smartphones ou pas pour les smartphones
si ça donne si ça délivre trop d'ondes
et électromagnétiques et magnétique
effectivement ça ça il y a une polémique
longtemps il y a une polémique sur les
téléphones où on disait que ça risquait
de donner des des troubles cérébraux et
notamment et que ça pouvait donner des
des cancers ça ça n'a jamais été prouvé
mais on commence à avoir quand même des
choses qui sont quand même curieuses par
rapport au smartphone on va en parler
hier par exemple il y a la marque à la
pomme qui présentait son nouveau
téléphone le numéro 15 et l'Agence
nationale des fréquences a interdit